[Musique]
one on abat la chance non j'y crois pas
ah bah alors là là ça s'appelle merci la
loi la r d de loi la compagnie démarche
en naviguant sur la loi la rivière li
geris les angles de marine la ville
d'orléans on est in the middle of the
loire orléans est là la ville d'orléans
aller sur des jetons de présence de la
communauté des marchands
[Musique]
c'est un jeton de présence de la
compagnie démarche en naviguant sur la
loire 2739 les mariniers était fédérer
dans la compagnie démarche en naviguant
sur la loire et les affluents descendant
en hissel en hissel celle-ci la loi la
compagnie des marchands les mariniers
les voituriers parrot il faisait partie
du commerce du royaume la loire c'était
un axe commercial c'était une autoroute
et donc les marchands il était fédérer
dans une communauté qui tenait assemblée
régulièrement à orléans pour défendre
les droits de navigation les droits de
balisage les problèmes de balisage de
bateaux échoués à nettoyer et c est
aussi tout les péages ya eu jusqu'à 190
ph sur la loi et donc la communauté des
marchands elle se réunissait à orléans
et les participants on leur donnait en
titre un peu comme aujourd'hui c'est des
dividendes pour les actionnaires il
avait un jeton de présence et cette
communauté qui tenait assemblée au camp
la marine de loire a disparu eba qui a
remplacé la communauté des marchands où
il ya écrit ici libertat et commercy et
hubert tass c'est à dire une bertha
c'est l'abondance le liberté la liberté
du commerce et la et l'abondance et bien
aujourd'hui ça a donné naissance à qui
au chantre de commerce et d'industrie et
dans les chambres de commerce et
d'industrie notamment à orléans on à la
continuité de ça on va aller y voir
[Musique]
on se retrouve dans le salon d'honneur
de la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
toujours avec notre pièce et on va se
retrouver ici devant une vitrine
exceptionnelle et le lien il est là la
communauté des marchands et des
bateliers acteurs clés du commerce sur
les rives de loire du 17e au 19e siècle
est à l'origine de la chambre de
commerce créée en 1803 la chambre de
commerce a d'ailleurs fait sienne leur
devise de la liberté du commerce n'est
la prospérité de la liberté du commerce
n'est la prospérité et donc cesse-t-on
de présence qui étaient alloués aux
membres de la communauté des marchands
quand il siégeait et pas les chambres de
commerce c'est pareil
regardez cet écrin est donc là on a des
pièces exceptionnelles
alors merci beaucoup de nous avoir
autorisés à ouvrir le trésor et là on a
donc les jetons de présence avec très
intéressant des moulages qui ont été
faits et regardez on est d'accord on est
raccord de la liberté du commerce n'est
la prospérité et tout ça ça démarre avec
la loi